week is no competition because he did so
good last week so let's see if he can
ride the momentum you guys know how the
song goes you guys want to sing it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys uh my name is Hans Kim
I'm from New Jersey so don't worry Texas
I'm racist too
yours is more the direct kind of racism
ours is more tax based
I love Arabic people especially when
they're in one piece
because they get a little PC during
historic moments
I love black people I just like keeping
my possessions more
I love Mexicans I love Home Depot I
think that's an amazing story
because everything you need to rob a
Home Depot is in a Home Depot
hahaha
if you're buying things at Home Depot
you're not thinking hard enough
all right that's why
[Applause]
that's why Hans Kim with a new 60
seconds thank you Tony oh hello Hans
hello Tony what are you thanking me for
I'm thinking I hope that was 60 seconds
um
no I said what are you thanking me oh
thank you oh just my entire career okay
perfect good just making sure we're on
the same page
I loved the Home Depot joke that was fun
thank you Tony okay
[Laughter]
take us through your process Hans when
you're writing a new minute every week
where are you doing it what's going on
well the Home Depot joke I wrote inside
of a Home Depot funny how that happens
right yeah I was like man uh there's so
much you could build so much stuff here
like you could even Rob this place
um I was building a little cat door for
my girlfriend ah
yes a cat door so the cat can go in and
out yeah so did she say that she wanted
that or did you just do that herself
hey babe I built you a cat door uh your
cat's missing huh okay
um okay so you're a bit of an
environmental comic so you're influenced
by wherever you're standing yeah but the
cat didn't make it into the bit this
week no no just right just overall
racism which was yeah that's fine but no
but nobody was spared it was nice it
really was it was very very racist black
people to keep your possessions warm
Arabic in one piece and Mexican Home
Depot joke but you're challenging people
to think right that's your point yeah I
want them to
hahaha
right racism right it's ironic your
presentation yeah yeah at least if
you're gonna be racist make it run no
yes right I think you had another punch
line and he stepped on it I think it was
a [__] joke on that cat door bit am I
right yes I knew it oh man think it's
all about cat doors and [__]
Roseanne Barr five I love that you were
like studied and offensive that's good
it's non-pc these [__] need to
be shook out of their comments thank you
Roseanne
you gotta put some Jew jokes in there
though I tell you gotta get the juice
right am I right
difficult they're so litigious
[Laughter]
that can go right in there you can mix
that right in there Hans what else is
going on this week
um I've been having a great time with my
girlfriend I stayed in in Austin this
week uh just did a bunch of shows at
Brian redbands Club thank you Brian for
having me
keep going come on tell us something
I'm hoping to get more spots thank you
Brian Jesus what a creep I uh I did what
are you gonna build him a [__] cat
door
I did a meet and greet after the show
and a very old lady uh grabbed my butt
and I was gonna grab her butt back but I
was like that's gonna hurt me more than
it's gonna hurt her that's true old
that's true you don't want to get me 92.
elderly lady folks elderly lady me too
jokes all right
I love it what else Hans give us
something good before we let you out of
here um I've been playing a little game
with my girlfriend called the rape
[Music]
well you've covered all the bases all
the bases
no stone left Unturned
this is a molest station away from a
full bingo card here tonight
so what is this game she's agreed to let
you rape her David can anybody play
you're not in my weight class
this game that you and your girlfriend I
was like hey come you wanna come cuddle
and she's like no because you're gonna
have sex with me and I was like come on
when am I gonna have sex tonight she's
like tomorrow I was like no not tomorrow
and I started chasing her
so there was really no rules written on
this game it was more of a not game more
of just a rape uh yeah that's pretty
realistic did she say
it's the next parties you all uh you all
might be called to testify in the future
yeah this is why we lock up phones
everybody uh
so uh let me ask you this and I probably
shouldn't because this answer is going
to decide whether or not this entire
segment gets edited out of the show but
I'm still curious to know did your
girlfriend at any point of this game say
the word no
yeah oh [__] all right
how did she handle that afterwards were
there any tears or anything like that
this is the number one live podcast in
the world people you're in good hands
don't worry
[Laughter]
she uh she won she kept me away uh oh
she won the game of rape yeah right bear
mace like what are we talking about uh
David keckner now we know why she wanted
the cat door
[Applause]
oh my god
oh it's for all the [__] to leave oh
okay there you go there you go Hans
well Hans this is very interesting the
game of rape uh really I think saved
your interview
how many of you guys think Hans did good
enough to not have to be challenged for
his spot next week that's pretty much
everybody in the room
nice guy with the bandana wants to see
you burn
[Applause]
Hans you're gonna go challengeless next
week my guess is you're gonna be lazy
and [__] come and stink it up but
we're gonna let you off the hook anyway
that's the that's this game actually has
rules to it
uh but congratulations another fun new
minute the Great and Powerful Hans Kim
everybody there he goes
a pre-picked another name and I'm